have you uh [__] with um Ayahuasca at
all hella hella
hello [__] with that [__] yeah I've been
I've been doing Ayahuasca since um
2016. yeah you're going you have you
have a shaman like yeah almost every
year I got a few Shaman that I uh Simons
saw men yeah yeah
what's the plural of Shaman shamans I
think it's shamans
um yeah I've been doing Ayahuasca since
2016 so I think I've probably done like
about
seven or eight ceremonies by this time
um and that has been super impactful for
me yeah I know people who's done it like
a weekend and it just like changed their
whole trajectory of life and like
they got rid of Habits Like immediately
almost like I think that's just been
super impactful for me going sober for
sure and just like
developing a new mindset and like
mastering my thoughts I want to do that
and I'm I'm really I mean I have access
to DMT I'm just scared to do it I'm just
like I don't know if like I just hear
about the dude I heard the damn t-shirt
is crazy it's like 15 minutes
yeah it's quick man I did one called the
five Meo DMT
um it's it's called the toad yeah that's
that's [__] my uh Mike Tyson talks about
is that the [__] you have to freebase
that's what you could call it it doesn't
look too different but it looks great it
looks crackheadish for sure
yo it was Ill though I'ma tell you the
truth the last time I did the toll
um
I was already kind of primed for the
experience because it was my second time
and I was in a good mind frame as
opposed to like a depressed place I'm
sure it changes your so the moment when
I inhaled it you blast off but from the
jump I was telling myself I'm releasing
myself from Fear I'm releasing myself
from Fear I'm releasing myself from fear
and I just had this Blissful experience
where
um I really communicated with my
grandmother uh who I never spoke to
with words because she didn't speak
English she was in Ghana and she spoke
Twee I didn't speak Twi so this was
probably the first conversation
conversation I've had with her and
she told me that
I should not be
inspired by her fear but by her love and
it was deep to me because
I'm not directly descended from slaves
in America so it didn't click to me
until she told me like
yes I carried fear and I gave you fear I
was enslaved we were enslaved we were
dominated and oppressed you know as
African people but when you think of me
do you think of my fear or do you think
of my love and that was so pivotal to me
not only because I felt like I was
having a conversation with my
grandmother that I could never speak to
right but also because it gave me
context that a lot of the fear I've
carried in my life predates me is not
just me like we're walking around with
generational trauma you know there are
things that happen in your bloodline
before you that are passed down to you
so now the question is how are you going
to deal with it you know what I mean are
you gonna unconsciously be guided by the
fear in your trauma bloodline or you're
going to learn to identify it and to
transcend it so the toad helped me
to work towards transcending it well
that's dope yeah I've had people tell me
my boy John John said he he lived like a
six-month life in that 15 minutes no he
said he's he's like bro I had a
girlfriend I went to a job interview
I was like and that and when he told me
what did that [__] do oh no hey when he
told me that I was like yeah I don't I
don't think I want to do that gang I
think I'm good like I want to do it my
[__] was a proper 15 minutes like yeah
yeah
[Music]
yo [__] crazy I was gonna ask you uh
talk about just like uh obviously you
know you got the Black Star Festival
which is in Africa which is dope that's
you and chance right yeah
um what what inspired you to do that
man you know it's really being on a
podcast in South Africa okay and I'm
talking to these dudes they got a dope
platform called sobering podcast hip-hop
heads they know everything bro they're
knowing verses from when I first met you
yeah kids these days music right you
know I mean all my [__] all chance [__]
Joey purp like I haven't heard anything
for a while my click my uh you know the
all the people that come up at the same
time as me they're knowing all the music
and it just struck me like how is it
that
we don't come and perform for these
people like
and they're huge fans of the music they
love the culture you know there's got to
be something that can be done about this
um because world tours happen but you
think that the kids in Ghana and Nigeria
and South Africa are oblivious to the
fact that they're never on the list
that's real you know what I mean you
call it a world tour people go to
Germany people go to Brazil but you're
leaving out a whole continent that not
only is you know the birthplace of black
people and Hip-hop music is
the most ubiquitous form of
communication black art form is taking a
world by storm and you know we're often
just completely out of touch with an
entire continent of people so that's
when I just started thinking about
yo there's got to be a way that we could
bring the black artists to come and
perform for the fans in Africa and to
meet the land and experience the
continent for real and it's going to
take
favors it's going to take friends it's
going to take
Mission and people buying in to that
mission uh but it's doable and
when Chaz came to visit me in Ghana I
just started to kick it to him and he
was just immediately on the same
wavelength and in that same mind frame
and it happened quickly that's dope man
well look the album's coming up
September 15th September 15th Victor
album any features yeah yeah
you know one that I'm really excited
about is
Jay Electronica oh shout out to jail he
gave me a crazy verse I bet I mean I
don't know if he's ever not given
someone a crazy person it would be hard
to it'd be really hard for him to rap
whack like he can't do it yeah like yeah
shout out to Jay elect
yo it's crazy uh I just I was just
having this conversation with somebody
and I just educated somebody on Crucial
Conflict
that's crazy because we're working on
Sample and Crucial Conflict right you
guys sampled I was telling him kids
these days which we used to play we used
to play that that [__] Trap House
Rock album when they used to come out
with us like I would have cold hard
never was in the group I remember all I
Used to Know style wild style yeah
that's right kilo Showdown it was it was
uh it was really cold hard and kilo that
would that would rock with us shout out
to the final tick a classic album yo
they would come out and crowd Surfer
when we were 17 they come out with us at
the Metro in Chicago be crowd surfing
these guys like kilo is a big guy yeah
200 plus pounds you know crowd surface I
remember those guys with their leather
overalls on the cover of that album and
I had the booklet them guys it's Legends
so um also shout out shots do or die
also another very undoing uh appreciated
both west side of Chicago you know
legends that brought a style
just to the world have you uh chopped it
up with Twitter I know twist is doing
like uh twist about a week ago he's
doing a lot he came out at the uh Acid
Rap oh dope well I know he's like doing
a lot in the like trying to like
properly
show people how to use guns in Chicago
yeah you know do it the legal way so
that [__] is dope super dope man well
look go get the album on the 15th can't
believe it's your second album I mean
technically it's like you're like six
right fifth six P's and all this stuff
internet tape we're not considering an
album yeah it basically is though I mean
hey shout out to this guy for people who
don't know I did a mixtape called Empire
business and you gave me orange soda
before it was like orange juice I did my
graphic designer [__] that up so was
it because I was trying to remember the
other day I was like was it me or was it
you I don't remember I just remember
when I put the artwork up you hit me
you're like it's orange soda bro also it
must have been but it was on my [__]
like well before internet tape dropped
yeah it was that was like before it came
out yeah shout out to man damn that's
crazy I didn't even remember that yes
and then semtex put it on uh like BBC
Radio classic UK Classic record uh I
appreciate you pulling up though man
that's a love boom fire